the body filters drugs from the
bloodstream and eliminates them in a
multi-step process called medication
excretion the kidneys are the major
route for drug
elimination most drugs exit the body
either unchanged or is drug metabolites
in
urine generally health professionals
refer to the ability of the kidneys to
filter blood as renal function
nephrons the functional and anatomical
units of the kidney filter blood
regulate fluid volume and pH and control
levels of electrolytes in the body each
nefron contains a renal
corpal and renal
tubule the renal corpal includes the
Bowman
capsule and glomerulus
and the renal tubule is composed of the
proximal
tubule Loop of
Henley distal
tubule and collecting
duct each component plays a role in
renal drug excretion a four-step process
that allows the kidneys to filter and
eliminate drugs from the body these
steps are glomular filtration passive
tubular
reabsorption active tubular secretion
and
excretion blood flows into the
glomerulus via a blood vessel larger in
diameter than the vessel draining blood
from the
glomerulus this difference in diameter
creates the high blood pressure
necessary to filter wastes from the
blood
the glomerulus functions as a molecular
C waste materials in water pass through
the Civ While most normal proteins and
cells are kept in the
bloodstream glomerula filtration removes
low molecular weight drugs from the
bloodstream the process of passive
reabsorption of water solutes and ions
begins in the proximal tu
Ule continues in the Henley
Loop and ends in the distal and
collecting
ducts water soluble drugs stay in the
tubule while unionized and lipid soluble
drugs are primarily reabsorbed across
renal
tubules after reabsorption lipid soluble
drugs travel through the bloodstream to
the liver
where certain liver enzymes such as the
cytochrome p450 enzyme complex
metabolize them into more water soluble
forms here we Show an example of this
process through the metabolism of pentab
barbital some drugs are not filtered
from the blood via the
glomerulus
instead special anionic and cationic
pumps in the walls of the renal tubu
actively transport the drugs from the
blood into the tubules and collecting
duct urine from the collecting ducts
travels through the uers where it is
collected and stored in the urinary
bladder until elimination from the
body
although the kidneys are the major route
for drug elimination medication
excretion can also occur
in lactating women through their breast
milk exhalation through the
lungs release into
bile and elimination through
saliva and
sweat